[Musique]
l'économie a très bien performé en 2021
une performance exceptionnelle mais on a
quand même
degré d'incertitude
[Musique]
composé dé votre portefeuille
ça va être un budget oraliste qu'on
demande à françois de nous c'est
d'arrêter de tout politiser
de la vie le logement la bouffe tout
coûte cher
c'est très payant politiquement
d'envoyer un chèque avec des élections
mais malheureusement économiquement ça
n'a pas de sens go c'est le moment ou
jamais de donner un coup de barre en
matière climatique
[Musique]
c'est ce qui était le plus attendu le
qu'on aide les québécois à faire face au
taux d'inflation qui est très élevé sous
plusieurs produits et services
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bonne fin
d'après midi si patrice roy toute
l'équipe de l'information de
radio-canada des images tournées un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui le premier ministre
flanqué de son ministre des finances
eric girard qui parle d'un budget
attendu sans se tromper on peut dire que
ce quatrième budget est en effet très
attendu pourquoi comme le dit monsieur
legault on va vous aider at il dit il ya
des gens qui attendent de l'aide le taux
d'inflation galope est important tout
coûte plus cher on en parle à tous les
soirs dans les télés journaux vous le
savez si vous faites le plein vous le
savez si vous allez à l'épicerie alors
qu'est ce que va faire éric girard
faut-il envoyer des chèques à tout le
monde aux gens qui en ont vraiment
besoin est ce qu'il y aura des baisses
d'impôts est ce que les tarifs
d'hydro-québec on va déjà se commettre
pour l'an prochain parce que si on suit
l'inflation ça pourrait faire mal
le déficit est ce que on va arriver un
déficit zéro plus vite que prévu
l'économie tourne à plein on est en plus
dans ce contexte de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre bref beaucoup de sujets pour
notre discussion près dépôt du budget
c'est à 16 heures que monsieur gérard va
déposer au salon bleu et dès qu'ils
aient déposé on va pouvoir en parler
avec moi vous les connaissez michel
serrault g bonsoir me bonjour michel
chroniqueur politique andréanne
st-arnaud notre collègue journal
spécialisé en économie et pierre andré
bouchard saint-amand vous êtes
économiste jette professeur à l'ena
bonjour à vous trois bonjour je commence
avec vous pierre andré bouchard
saint-amand le contexte économique bien
sûr l'éléphant dans la pièce c'est
l'inflation mais parlez moi un peu du
contexte des finances publiques dans
quelle posture se trouve le ministre
eric girard dans une posture où il peut
anticiper des revenus stables sur
plusieurs et une croissance de ses
dépenses notamment en lien avec les
dépenses de santé c'est un gouvernement
qui nous a habitués à une croissance des
revenus très très stable donc très peu
de changements dans
l'acide budgétaire les revenus et qui a
spécialisé ces dépenses par choix dans
l'économie l'innovation
mais évidemment pandémie oblige que de
dépenser énormément aussi en santé y at
il
la suit andré monsieur bush à
saint-amand y at il une grande marge de
manoeuvre
il a parlé d'imprévisibilité il ya la
guerre et à l'inflation dont je parlais
est ce qu'il y a quand même une marge de
manoeuvre actuellement pour la santé
pour des baisses d'impôts pour des
chèques et c'est ce que le ministre
girard a indiqué dans les derniers jours
c'est qu'il avait une marge de manoeuvre
plus grande que celle qu'il anticipait
alors il l'a indiqué dans un premier
temps que son déficit budgétaire était
moins important que prévu probablement
parce qu'on a une très bonne reprise
mais toujours en déficit donc la
question là un peu c'est celle que vous
avez soulevé en introduction à quel
point ce que ce gouvernement le souhaite
maintenir le cap sur ces les propos de
monsieur girard versus devancé par
exemple l'atteinte de l'équilibré
budgétaire
peut-être qu à la veille d'une élection
on va être tentée de justement
satisfaire peut-être plus la dépense que
la résorption du déficit les dépenses
qui ont progressé de 4,5 pour ça on
verra dans quelle mesure et progressent
pour l'an prochain andréanne jour posent
la même question parce qu'il ya un piège
si on aide entre guillemets trop de
monde ça donne de l'air à l'inflation ça
met de l'huile sur le feu oui jusqu'à un
certain point mais tout va dépendre
évidemment du montant vous savez la
prestation exceptionnelle qui avaient
été promises l'automne passé qui était
versée au début de l'année c'était 400
dollars pour les couples qui vernier
moins de cinquante six mille dollars et
275 $ pour les personnes seules qui
gagnaient moins de 51 mille dollars
c'est bien là on s'attend à plus est ce
que ce sera doublé est ce qu'on va
également les le nombre de personnes qui
vont en profiter tout va dépendre du
montant et du spectre à fait acquis va
s'adresser cette aide là tous
conviennent que oui c'est un coup de
pouce est ce que ça va changer le monde
non est-ce que ça va soudainement faire
en sorte que votre pouvoir d'achat vont
réellement augmenté c'est pas
garantissent donc est-ce que ça va
nécessairement alimenter l'inflation
peut-être pas de manière très soutenue
mais c'est une aide qui est attendu
effectivement pour donner un peu d'air
dans le budget des ménages et qui n'en
peuvent plus devant la hausse des prix
de l'essence et qui ont explosé vous
savez quand on parle d'une inflation qui
est soutenu 5,4 pour cent ce sont les
derniers chiffres qu'on aime et on sait
que ça va être encore révisée à la
hausse parce que dans les dernières
semaines les prix de l'essence entre
autres ont grimpé encore plus que ça se
reflète dans les coûts de transport et
finalement dans les coupes d'à peu près
tous les produits qu'on consomme au jour
le jour alors oui de manière d'une
manière ou d'une autre l'inflation est
appelée à grimper ça c'est clair je suis
auger c'était le dernier budget avant la
campagne électorale du mois de septembre
prochain élection mois d'octobre
prochain veut veut pas ça joue là sur le
goût au bout dire j'ai demandé que le
budget ne soient propres électorale il
l'est ne serait ce qu'à cause du
calendrier à cause d'autres
considérations aussi c'est évident la
question c'est comment on va cibler
justement cette aide pour l'inflation un
moment donné il était question même
sujet là il y avait fait allusion un
chèque pour tout le monde c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de sous ça parce qu'il ya 4
millions de presque 4 millions de
contribuables au québec alors c'est
peut-être possible de faire ça comment
on cible après ça comment par quel
mécanisme on le fait mais il est clair
que
les citoyens le savent autant la pompe
qu'à l'épicerie à l'épicerie s'est quand
même rendu vraiment très dans certains
secteurs très importants l'inflation et
ça les gens le sentent le voit tous les
jours alors ils s'attendent à de l'aide
du gouvernement là dessus et on était
presque six mois jour pour jour du
scrutin c'est clair que le gouvernement
va vouloir faire quelque chose là dessus
sinon ça risque d'être lui qui va payer
les pots cassés et sûr que je le groupe
a l'intention de se laisser avoir par
son avant d'aller rejoindre pascal point
l'anah québec pierre andré bouchard
saint-amand qu'elle est quelle serait la
manière économiquement la plus efficace
pour aider les gens qui en arrachent
face à l'augmentation des prix michel
faire un très bon point c'est un
arbitrage entre combien de personnes
dans ce ca quel point on donne en niveau
pour vous donner une idée la 200 $ à 4.4
millions de contribuables ceux qui
paient de l'impôt c'est une dépense de 1
milliard un petit peu moins 15 milliards
si on doublait le montant bien sûr 2
milliards donc ça commence à des
montants substantif pour des petits
chèques si on résume donc si on veut
cibler le donner des montants plus
importants peut-être à ce moment l'un
est introduire une zone à partir duquel
on diminue les montants et là une
question c'est à partir de quel revenu
alors le revenu mondial pour un ménage
ses trente mille soixante mille dollars
à peu près pour deux un couple de deux
revenus là on pourrait se dire que si on
cherche à aider les gens là qui ont pas
reçus des d'autrement qui en arrachent
ton peut-être un petit peu au dessus de
ça mais à partir de son commence à
cibler des gens qui ont peut-être pas
besoin de ce montant là dans le contexte
donc j'essaie faut être quand même
chirurgicales parce sinon ça peut être
contre productif et très coûteux comme
vous dites vous restez là je vais à
québec pascal point la bombe jour vous
êtes à l'assemblée nationale les
attentes de l'opposition ils ont été
clairement établie
les batteries c'est sûr que l'opposition
fait bien attention de pas trop
critiquer l'idée de cette remise en
argent
un chèque comme ça qui va être envoyée
aux contribuables québécois parce que la
position sait très bien que c'est une
mesure qui va être populaire après une
partie de l'électorat mais en même temps
on directrice et une mesure qui est
assez spontané leurs soins chèque et
ensuite il ya plus des faits pour aider
les québécois à lutter contre les effets
néfastes de l'inflation alors on en
quelque chose de plus structuré on note
aussi de côté de l'opposition que en ce
moment c'est difficile de se loger donc
s'approche davantage d'investissements
en logements abordables difficile pour
les parents d'avoir une place en
garderie il attend aussi pour les
chirurgies alors oui que les demandes de
l'opposition sont importants on veut
plus qu'un chèque finalement les
sentences seulement les partis
d'opposition à québec
tout le monde doit acheter ses produits
essentiels à la pharmacie que ce soit
des médicaments sans ordonnance à ce
soit savons que ce soit des fins peu
importe qu'on enlève la tvq sur ces
produits là ça c'est structurant que nos
concitoyens puissent respirer un peu
notamment
considérant la crise du coût de la vie
une modulation de cette allocation la
fonction des revenus donc les gens qui
gagnent moins d'argent lors plus dans
leurs poches et ceux et celles qui ont
l'opportunité de contribuer bien
effectivement il sera aux autres aussi
reconnu avec notre allocation sur le
pouvoir d'achat le problème avec un
chèque c'est que c'est très payant
politiquement d'envoyer un chèque avec
des élections pour acheter des votes
mais malheureusement économiquement ça
n'a pas de sens
petite note de bas de page mais qu'ils
arrêtent quand même important on voit
beaucoup de gens derrière vous pascal
premier budget en deux ans
comme avant j'allais dire avec un huis
clos on est ample et les journalistes
sont enfermés depuis ce matin il ya deux
huis clos pour les experts pour les
journalistes on n'est pas en virtuel
cette année cent et un vrai
et justement on va pouvoir les cueillir
des réactions après la lecture du budget
pour vous expliquer comment les villes
réagissent comment les personnes qui
représentent par exemple c'était les
anglais ce qui représente les plus
démunis comment ces gens ne réagissent
que mal le conseil du patronat lors des
réactions pour vous un peu plus tard
dans l'émission très bien tout de suite
et on retrouve colin côté paul est à
québec vous avez pu parler à des
citoyens
oui on s'est promené dans les rues de
québec qui est patrie c'est vraiment ce
qu'on remarque d'abord sait qu'il est
attendu ce budget-là pas seulement par
les analystes pas seulement par les
journalistes et les politiciens mais
vraiment monsieur madame tout le monde
est là quand je dis monsieur madame tout
le monde c'est des gens issus un peu de
tous les profils j'ai autant parler avec
des gens retraités des gens qui vivent
seuls des gens qui sont corps d'un jeune
famille c'est quand même un sac ou de
l'argent et partout on dit la même chose
on remarque que les achats de base des
achats qu'on faisait à chaque semaine
sans problème auparavant bel ça commence
à être plus compliqué on doit calculer
notamment on en a beaucoup parlé
l'essence l'épicerie tout ça donc moi je
demandais aux gens comment vous le
sentez dans vos finances on est bon on
le sent on fait attention donc ça ça
veut dire que tout le monde a des
attentes dans ce budget là parce que les
électeurs ne sont pas dupes ton savoir
une élection donc on a ans attendait une
part du gâteau je le dirai comme ça donc
sans plus tarder on peut regarder
quelques commentaires de ces personnes à
mieux pas avoir d'attentes sur quelque
chose dont on ramasse 6 en octobre ce
que j'ai un peu de temps mais ils ont
dit déjà qu'ils allaient envoyer des
chèques on espère juste qu'il n'y a pas
de restriction et que tout le monde aura
droit à quelque chose ça nous soulagera
sais quel que soit le montant en tout
cas on aimerait bien que
tout le monde soit plus en compte
beaucoup de conséquences qui sont
appliqués à l'individu je pense que les
petites familles payent cher aussi pour
ça des fois j'ai l'impression que les
corporations sont peut-être un petit peu
moins interpellé j'ai l'impression qu'on
précède un petit peu mieux équilibrer
les choses oui longtemps d'avoir dans
une maison de personnes à angers puis
quand on écoute tout le monde quand on
ose parler il faudrait qu'il fasse
quelque chose pour ceux qui s'appuient
de bourse il ya des gens qui ont de
l'argent ira manger des pensions sont
pas assez élevés
merci beaucoup c'est un très bon point
merci je vais poser la question andré
est né pierre andré entre haute et
michel j'ai reçu hier on a fait un
reportage sur les attentes prévu jetair
et j'ai reçu un nombre de courriels
incroyable des personnes âgées des
personnes de 60 ans retraité qui disent
oui c'est vrai que les salaires ne
suivent pas l'inflation
les salaires ont augmenté de 3%
inflation et à 5,4 mais nous les
retraités on fait quoi est ce que le
ministre
andréanne à une poignée un levier pour
faire quelque chose mais il est clair
que les demandes sont pressantes de la
part des personnes qui sont plus âgées
qui vivent d'une pension par exemple qui
dans certains cas n'est point d'excès ou
encore qui réclame de la part des
gouvernements que ce soit au québec ou
ottawa d'avoir plus de plus d'être
effectivement parce que certains se
retrouvent dans une situation de
pauvreté est ce que le ministre choisira
par exemple d'avoir une prestation
spécifique pour eux vous avez évoqué des
personnes âgées mais moi aussi j'ai reçu
beaucoup de courriels on a posé une
question similaire aux téléspectateurs
hier des gens qui me disaient mais dans
le cas des personnes seules également on
vise beaucoup des familles avec
certaines prestations du soutien
financier mais ça coûte plus cher vivre
seul on doit assumer seul son loyer
l'épicerie est chez terra donc la charge
parfois est encore plus lourde ce sera
difficile de cibler dans ce que la des
personnes seules ou des personnes plus
âgées mais il ya effectivement tout un
éventail de personnes qui réclament de
l'aide l'inflation ne fait pas de
distinction sur qui achète sa touche
absolument tout le monde en ce moment
peut-être seulement les sens où là
certaines personnes choisissent par
exemple le transport actif transports en
commun que parfois on peut faire un
choix mais on n'a pas le choix demain
j'ai à l'épicerie laon subito cette
hausse des prix puis andré bouchât
notamment sur cette question-là de quels
sont les leviers les plus efficaces on
en parlait tout à l'heure pour aider les
gens qui en ont besoin mais commençons
par les retraités très bien la première
caractéristique de l'inflation qu'on est
en train de vivre c'est que les treize
sournoisement elle est arrivée très
rapidement en très peu de temps si bien
qu'elle génère beaucoup de réactions à
cause de son le pauvre venir en quelque
sorte il est anticipé mais on l'a pas vu
venir pour les personnes retraitées le
manière de manière à travers lequel le
gouvernement pour réfléchir en fait à
transférer de l'aed toujours d'abord à
travers le régime fiscal avec des
mesures spécifiques pour les années où
les retraités une autre approche pour
être à travers les régimes de retraite
d'une bonification des rentes par
exemple des régimes publics
la difficulté avec cette deuxième
approche là par contre c'est qu'elle est
généralement structurantes c'est à dire
que c'est très difficile de revenir en
arrière sur une annonce de cette nature
là si bien qu'on pourrait imaginer
quelques
feux rouges en interne en étant
l'appareil public pour ça salaire
minimum michel peur on en parlera aussi
à 15 de l'ail et il ya une annonce de
hausse
déjà hier nous disait ça va prendre ça
il faut qu'on suive derrière ou est
traditionnellement québec ce 1er mai
qu'on a eu juste le salaire minimum il
faudra voir si dans les mesures
électoralistes le gouvernement décide
portes exceptionnellement parce qu'on a
une situation d'inflation qu'on avait
prévu on pourrait avoir une eau une
hausse moyenne du soleil immeuble
six mois va le 1er mai mais ça semble
pas être dans les cartes une des choses
aussi que le gouvernement doit regarder
ces logements on a on le voyait dans les
journaux au cours des derniers jours il
ya plein de régions du québec où il ya
une pénurie de main d'oeuvre et la
pénurie est accentuée par le fait y'a
pas de logement dans ces régions là et
ça le gouvernement haut des poignets
pour faire ça il ya des programmes de
logement social et il peut faire des
programmes de des de la construction de
nouveaux logements et ça peut aller
assez vite cela comme un fait économique
s'est pas trop long alors peut-être que
c'est une des voies que le milieu des
finances ou d'employés andréanne on
parle de l'eau michel parent de logement
à la santé la ''refondation'' qu'on dit
plus réforme on dit refondation du
système de santé même si je dis bedie ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'argent on
imagine que ça va prendre des
investissements aussi donc santé
logement éducation
environnement dans quelle mesure il a
les moyens de ses ambitions
mais qu'est il est clair qu'avec leur
reprise économique le ministre gérard a
beaucoup insisté là dessus dans les
derniers jours la croissance économique
au québec a été exceptionnel c'est clair
qu'on compare avec une année où en
raison de la pandémie la croissance est
anémique évidemment mais on parle d'un
rebond là on avait prévu ccnmi % de
progression le ministre a dit on va
réviser seul légèrement à la baisse mais
ça devrait tourner aux ti au-dessus de
6% donc la croissance économique les
revenus sont au rendez-vous ce qu'on a
évoqué d'ailleurs jeter un coup d'oeil
tout à l'heure la revue financière du
gouvernement pour les six premiers mois
de l'exercice financier ces 10 milliards
de dollars de plus de revenus autonomes
donc oui on génère de l'argent
supplémentaire avec les grands traits
d'impôt sur les sociétés l'impôt des
particuliers les taxes à la consommation
alors que tout coûte plus cher avec les
taxe évidemment ça génère plus de
revenus pour le gouvernement taxe sur
l'essence même chose on a donc on est
plus confortable si vous voulez quoi qu
on a toujours cet objectif de retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2027 2028 on a
choisi de ne pas de devancer la cible on
a dit vouloir atteindre l'objectif de
l'équilibré budgétaire sans que les gens
s'en rendent trop quand on veut pas se
serrer la ceinture sur son entrée en
attente de mots j'en reste hérité de
choses comme ça non parce que en ce
moment il ya énormément d'incertitudes
également ça aussi on a insisté là
dessus hier entre autres le ministre
disait savez avec la guerre en ukraine
avec la pandémie qui est toujours en
toile de fond même si on en parle peut
être moins l'inflation et des facteurs
de risque en ce moment pour l'économie
et donc pour les rentrées de revenus
pour le gouvernement
on a estimé à peu près 25 % le risque
d'une récession possible donc ça ça ne
nous prend pas au bout du nez mais il
faut considérer ça dans les calculs
alors on va se garder et son le verrons
dans le budget tout à l'heure une bonne
marge de manoeuvre pour faire face à
toute éventualité
mais on va choisir avec les revenus
supplémentaires qui ont été générés
grâce à la croissance où on aide les
québécois et de quelle manière on réduit
le déficit on pourrait l'atteindre plus
tôt que prévu l'équilibré budgétaire
c'est ce que disait pierre andré
bouchard cette amende avec l'entrée
d'argent les entrées d'argent qui à
l'économie qui roulent très rapidement
il pourrait atteindre plus vite le
déficit mais ils veulent aussi baisser
les impôts avant les élections ils
veulent aussi redonner un peu d'argent
donc c'est un équilibre entre les
nouvelles dépenses et l'espace qu'on
veut donner aux citoyens ce serait très
surprenant de voir le gouvernement met
de l'avant des mesures des changements
qu'on appellerait structurels au régime
fiscal donc on en a déjà discuté par
exemple sur vos ongles d'une potentielle
baisse de taxes sur l'essence ou d'une
réduction des impôts en termes de taux
marginaux d'imposition
je me permets de spéculer que ce serait
peu probable
ce que je pense qu'ils aient plus dans
l'ordre du possible c'est une mesure
ciblée aux rapports d'impôt de cette
année qui justement permettre aux gens
d'être soulagé cette année mais
malheureusement pour les années
subséquentes ne serait probablement pas
parfaitement partie du régime on refera
pas toutes leurs lots jury de la
fiscalité on va aller pompe du helmand
pour aider pendant une période
d'inflation élevée merci vous restez là
je vais à moncton y'avait dépôt d'un
budget aujourd'hui à moncton
janick gaudin est à moncton bonjour je
n'ai
bonjour patrice à fredericton tout juste
devant la l'assemblée législative
et oui non et pas de souci est oui avait
un budget présenté ici aujourd'hui et le
budget global du nouveau brunswick ces
11 milliards de dollars et puis rareté
au cours des deux dernières années on a
affiché des surplus quand même important
cette année on parle d'un surplus de 488
millions de dollars et on pouvait
peut-être s'attendre à des gros annonce
aujourd'hui on en celui jamais pas
vraiment de grands chantiers un budget
qui limite quand même ses dépenses
mais pour aider à l'inflation par
exemple il ya notamment des
investissements qui seront faits pour
réduire les impôts sur le revenu des
particuliers
et ça c'est une des mesures pour aider
les gens à faire face à cette inflation
est
au prix de l'essence beaucoup ces
derniers temps et pour le logement je
vous montre un tableau on va aider les
propriétaires d'immeubles à logements en
réduisant de 50% leurs impôts fonciers
sur trois ans on va aussi aider les
propriétaires de foyers soit en
réduisant leurs impôts fonciers de 15 %
sur trois ans ainsi que les commerces
d'usinés propriétaires de terrains 15%
de réduction de l'impôt foncier sur
trois ans et on souhaite on espère
contrer la flambée du coût des loyers
avec ce genre de mesure et on va aussi
installer un plafond on ne pourra pas si
on est propriétaires de logements
augmenter davantage que 3,8 pour cent
par année le prix du loyer ce qui
n'existait pas comme mesure auparavant
mais pour plusieurs c'est insuffisant je
viens d'écouter le ministre finances qui
est content de pouvoir dépenser un peu
plus avec ce surplus budgétaires cette
année et d'autres qui réagissent à ces
mesures concernant le logement
les fenêtres par une diminution au
niveau des locataires donc s'oppose aux
s'inquiétant le feu aussi qu'ils ont
bloquée l'augmentation à trois points 8
% pour un an
c'est un bon qui m'aime pas suffisant
pour les aider savoir mettre un peu de
baume sur la plaie béante qui est le
manque de logements abordables offrant
strict
très intéressant de ces mesures dans le
domaine du logement taxes foncières
plafond d'augmentation des loyers on
verra s'il ya quelque chose similaire au
québec ou pas je n'ai gaudin fredericton
merci
pascal point là nous rebonjour on
connaît déjà certains détails oui du
budget des crédits au dépose les crédits
pour l'année avant le budget général des
dépenses
oui ça s'est déposée à l'assemblée
nationale juste avant la période de
questions le jour du budget donc on les
a depuis peu près une heure les crédits
budgétaires évidemment c'est le budget
qui fait foi de tout mais j'ai trouvé
une information intéressante pour vous
patrice dans les crédits budgétaires
combien le gouvernement dépense thil
depuis le début de la pandémie pour
lutter justement contre la corvette 19
le gouvernement le chiffre à chaque
année combien ça coûte en prime pour le
personnel médical pour maintenir les
centres de vaccination centres de
dépistage en matériel médical
supplémentaire mais regardez le tableau
qu'on vous a préparé alors pour l'année
2020 2021 premières années de la
pandémie ça avait coûté 11 milliards et
demi de dollars ce qui est énorme a dans
le budget du québec oiiq c'est énorme
l'année suivante 21 22 on était à 9
milliards et puis pour l'année 2022 2023
une hypothèque de transition ou de fin
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire on passe à
deux milliards et demi de dollars ça
demeure important mais admettez que
c'est quand même beaucoup moins que ce
qu'on dépensait le gouvernement prévoit
vraiment le dépenser moins pour lutter
contre la coved 19 dans les crédits
aussi budgétaire on voit les différents
postes de dépenses par ministère donc
selon les différentes missions du
gouvernement encore une fois santé
éducation il ya beaucoup de dépenses
supplémentaires on voit également qu'il
va y avoir des sommes pour le logement
abordable c'est important pour ceux qui
ont de la difficulté justement à trouver
un appartement ou un logement et puis
aussi on voit des sommes pour améliorer
la réussite scolaire en éducation ça va
être intéressant aussi de suivre ça
évidemment c'est le budget qui fait foi
de tout dans quelques minutes merci
beaucoup pascal on se retrouve avec des
réactions que vous aurez un show après à
le dépôt de ce budget merci au revoir à
leur tour de table en haletant d'un
dernier tour de table avant le dépôt du
budget au salon bleu un michel c andrée
anne et pierre andré qu'est-ce que vous
que quelques chiffres vous surveiller
particulièrement la quelques minutes du
dépôt pierre-andré je vous je voulais
vous fait plonger le premier d'abord
regardé qu'est ce qui va être annoncé
sur le plan de l'inflation donc
justement sur le plan des mesures
fiscales mais aussi les programmes de
soutien au revenu par exemple est prisé
bourse ou l'aide sociale pour les
personnes qui ne paient pas d'impôts
puis ensuite spécialité oblige ce qui se
passe en éducation et en enseignement
supérieur je vais regarder ça d'assez
près pour voir ce qui arrive aux
universités québécoises oui et
d'ailleurs parlant d'une université je
sais pas si on est des images il ya une
manifestation qui a été qu'on a c'est
terminé la manifestion me dit on verra
des images plus tard dans les bulletins
ils étaient quelques milliers ou à
montréal parce que ça fait dix ans
michel serveurs par le maire de
reillanne d'abord que le chiffre que
vous surveillez vous je pense que s'il
ya un chiffre qui va résumer le budget
d'aujourd'hui c'est quel sera le montant
sur le chèque de l'inflation est ce que
ce sera un chèque de chèques mais quel
est le montant total auxquels le peuvent
s'attendre les québécois je pense que
c'est ce qui va résumer la journée
d'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils risquent
d'éclipser les prévisions de croissance
budgétaire et cetera l'autre aspect que
je vais surveiller de près qu'est ce qui
va arriver avec la les tarifs
d'hydro-québec on avait laissé entendre
qu'avec l'inflation puisque les tarifs
seront dorénavant établi en fonction de
la progression de l'inflation ça
pourrait dépasser les 5 % l'augmentation
au 1er avril 2023 or dans les derniers
jours le gouvernement a laissé entendre
qu'on ne laisserait pas se passer est ce
qu'on voit les limites et est-ce qu'on
veut les geler ça aussi ça tous les
budgets et des québécois est-ce qu'on va
recréer la régie de l'énergie qui est
totalement démantelée parce qu'elle
avait un gros plus plus effacé ce qu'on
va créer un mécanisme bon à voir michel
roger qu'est-ce que vous surveillez en
particulier monsieur girard a dit la
semaine dernière qu'il fallait pas
abandonner les missions essentielles de
l'état il y en a souligné trois santé
éducation transports en commun en disant
des investissements là dedans c'est des
investissements dans l'avenir de
l'économie québécoise et il faut pas que
nous cessions d'investir là dedans alors
est ce que voyant des augmentations de
budget dans malgré les difficultés
financières actuelles est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des augmentations de budget
conséquente dans ces trois missions de
l'état là je serai jouer très curieux de
voir ce que c'est parce que pour une
petite dernière prendrait pour
les finances publiques l'équilibré
budgétaire il ya pas beaucoup de grandes
grandes inquiétudes
eux ils avaient mis 27 28 comme cible
déficit zéro mais les gens c'est pas ça
qui préoccupent actuellement il faut
donner crédit l'eau il revient lieu un
excellent travail qui a été fait par le
précédent gouvernement pour ramener les
finances publiques sous contrôle en
matière de revenus et de dépenses et le
ministre gérard chercher à garder le cap
face à cette orientation là malgré
évidemment une pandémie qui a été
extrêmement difficile
si je devais souligné peut-être une
tache noire au profil actuel c'est très
certainement le fait qu'on a levé la loi
sur l'équilibré budgétaire de par les
conditions à laquelle on se trouve pour
retarder justement la teinte
du déficit zéro très bien je rappelle
27-28 merci gerald vous êtes libérés
n'ont pas complètement parce que vous
vous devez vous est pris avec le secret
budgétaire jusqu'au moment à la seconde
où le ministre va déposer sur la table
un petit mot sur site et comme avant
quoi avec beaucoup de monde autour et
oui à peu près avec beaucoup de
documents je vous le monde parce que le
ministre de l' montré hier le budget
avec les journalistes dans le huis-clos
essentiellement parce qu'on avait fait
2vic l'eau exceptionnellement vous savez
ce huis clos c'est ce moment qui dure de
6 de 5 à 7 heures où on étudie le budget
et donc on n'avait pas comme journaliste
accès aux experts aux économistes aux
fiscalistes et au lobé et les groupes
socioéconomiques qui était dans un autre
vie clos aujourd'hui mais on pouvait
échanger bien sûr avec les membres de la
fonction publique du ministère des
finances et du secrétariat au trésor
donc c'est presque normal je vous dirais
patrice je me rappelle il ya deux ans on
était ici le 10 mars 2020 et c'était
quelques heures avant finalement que
tout se déclenche sur la coved 19 on
n'était pas aussi nombreux aujourd'hui
mais ça faisait du bien de de retrouver
un peu des collègues et de retrouver
cette ambiance qu est le budget qui est
un peu le super bowl du ministre des
finances je dirais est le vôtre ou si
oui en partie c'est peut-être moins
agréable que de jouer au football parce
qu'il faut se casser la tête la journée
à étudier le budget je vais pas vous
torturer tôt parce qu'on voudrait
surtout pas et ça s'est jamais jamais
exactement je peux vous échappiez mais
êtes vous est ce qu'il ya une mesure qui
vous a surpris moi non
est-ce qu'ils ne mesurent que
j'attendais oui mais je voudrais pas
combien très bien et il ya beaucoup de
jacky l'ata ya beaucoup de gens qui la
tan selon l'expression ya toujours une
surprise dans un but gerald ce serait
bien la première fois
[Musique]
que gérard mesdames et messieurs
pourquoi on s'amuse c'est que monsieur
gérard est en route il va arriver au
salon bleu et budget doit être foré
expliquer pourquoi
c'est pas par plaisir c'est que le
budget doit être déposé et c'est normal
devant les élus de l'assemblée nationale
et là il est lu par le minefi n'a alors
si nous on en parle est bien sûr qu'il
ait révélé dans des huis clos avant tout
vos collègues et à vous de gérer ces
listes uniques l'ont encadrée patrice
ans parce que la sûreté du québec nous
encadrent nous surveille on n'a pas nos
téléphones cellulaires on n'a pas accès
à aucune commune questions extérieures
durant le huis clos justement pour
protéger cette information qui doit
sortir au moment où le ministre commence
à parler à l'assemblée nationale et
michel c'est vous souvenez de deux
épisodes où on avait filmé par mégarde
un budget a fallu qu'elle va le
présenter en pleine nuit il ya eu il ya
eu des cas comme ça dans l'histoire à
une école ya eu plusieurs codes une fois
il y avait été volé chez l'imprimeur une
autre fois ce sera pire que je nomme je
me souviens à ottawa le ministre mackay
n'avait changé la fiscalité de plein de
choses y compris l'étalement du revenu
des artistes et des joueurs de rock et
lille toutes les équipes canadiennes
dans l'hymne national d'aller à ottawa
faire changer ça il a changé son budget
par un mini budget présenté à 5 heures
de l'après-midi le 23 décembre il y
avait beaucoup de parties de noël en
cours et il y avait beaucoup de gens me
disent qu'ils trouvaient que c'était
vraiment pas drôle andréanne
historiquement aussi le secret c'est que
ça a un impact sur les marchés alors on
veut que ça soit juste pour tout le
monde à la même heure à la taxation c
est ce que c'est tout si nécessaire
cavage je sais pas jouer je vous pose la
question oui je pense que c'est
nécessaire que ces informations là
soient dévoilés à tout le monde en même
temps parce qu'on ne s'agit pas
d'informations privilégiées on sait ce
sont des documents qui doivent être
rendus public tout au même moment c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles on fait ça après 16 heures
après la fermeture des marchés et vous
savez puisqu'on est dans un peu dans
l'anecdote je parlais avec le ministère
des finances dans les derniers jours qui
me disait traditionnellement il ya à peu
près mille trois cents personnes qui
sont réunis en huit lots et là je parle
avant la pandémie on arrive d'une
envergure l'envergure d'à peu près le
tiers cette année par mesure de prudence
le tout simplement et ça coûte en fait
ça coûtait historiquement à peu près
cent mille dollars à retenir ce huit
clos penser justement mesures de
sécurité des infrastructures les
installations la nourriture et cetera
donc la facture est peut-être un petit
peu réduite cette année et autre
particularité le budget que gerald vous
a montré le fameux document papier on va
en voir de moins en moins on vise mais
on n'a pas de ces bleus mais à s'en
aller vers une version de plus en plus
numérique on a réduit de moitié
d'ailleurs le tirage de ce document
cette année pierre andré bouchât cet
amas par la queue giral ne peut pas
parler en refaisant une synthèse de
l'état de l'économie du québec
aujourd'hui au moment où monsieur gérard
dépose le budget comment vous qualifier
l'état de l'économie très bien d'abord
rappelé un de
l'initiative parlementaire c'est une
prérogative constitutionnelle qui
appartient au gouvernement si le budget
déposé d'abord à l'assemblée nationale
c'est constitutionnellement requis au
canada que ce soit fait alors même si on
voulait faire un coup d'éclat un peu
d'avancé légalement interdite l'économie
québécoise est en bonne posture une
bonne reprise présentement c'est ce que
le ministre des finances a suggéré hier
l'or ont un point tel que le déficit est
moins important que prévu dont on va
justement écoutez monsieur gérard au
début et dès que on aura fait quelques
minutes gérald pourra nous donner les
grandes lignes de ce 4e budget du
gouvernement de la carte qu'on écoute
news
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président j'ai l'honneur de
présenter aujourd'hui le budget du
québec c'est le quatrième budget de ce
gouvernement je suis très fier de vous
présenter ce budget que nous avons
préparée dans des circonstances encore
une fois particulière nous venons de
passer deux années en pandémie depuis
mars 2020 la maladie a fait plus de 14
mille décès chez nos concitoyens du
québec et plus de 6 millions de
personnes en sont décédées
à travers la mort
souvenons nous de ceux qui nous ont
quittés trop tôt
notre combat contre la coved 19 a
bouleversé notre quotidien à changer nos
habitudes et a provoqué l'isolément d'un
grand nombre d'entre nous les personnes
ont dû revoir leur mode de vie et les
entreprises ont dû revoir leurs façons
de faire nos institutions publiques ont
donné des services malgré tout on pense
tout de suite aux écoles qui sont
demeurées ouvertes pour le bien des
enfants
les québécois se sont adaptés à leur
nouvelle réalité pandémique et ont
relevé le défi de la résilience
la pandémie a eu également un impact
important sur les finances publiques
c'est inévitable quand plusieurs
secteurs de l'économie tourne au ralenti
le soutien important que nous avons
accordé aux citoyens aux entreprises a
également amené le gouvernement à
augmenter significativement les défenses
dans ce contexte je crois qu'on peut à
free affirmé que le québec est
persévérant notre population a relevé le
défi de combattre la pandémie en dépit
de toutes les contraintes que cela a
représenté
et c'est avec la même persévérance que
nous ferons face aux turbulences de
l'économie mondiale le budget que je
présente aujourd'hui s'inscrit en effet
dans un contexte de grande incertitude
on ne sait pas comment la pandémie peut
évoluer l'inflation est importante en ce
début d'année et les banques centrales
effectué un resserrement de leur
politique monétaire à cela s'ajoute le
contexte géopolitique tendu marqué par
l'invasion de l'ukraine dans la nuit
nous constatons que notre économie a
récupéré rapidement ce qu'elle avait
perdu durant la pandémie notre
croissance économique a été plus
soutenue que dans le reste du canada en
2021 le pib du québec s'est accru de 6
points 3% après avoir enregistré un
recul de 5 points 5 % en 2020 le marché
du travail est de retour est ce qu'il
était avant la pandémie c'est à dire au
plein emploi en février le taux de
chômage au québec était de 4 5% soit le
plus bas au canada
c'est grâce à la persévérance des
québécois ainsi qu'au soutien les
gouvernements que nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui en si bonne position
économique nous pouvons tous être fiers
du résultat de nos efforts de façon
générale sinon on regarde en avant
l'économie du québec restera dynamique
en 2022 2023 malgré un début d'année
ralentie par les mesures sanitaires liés
à l'émergence du variant au micro la
croissance poursuivre l'activité
économique devrait atteindre 2 7% en
2022 et revenir à 2 % en 2003 pendant
que monsieur gérard continue la lecture
de son budget gérad de maintenant vous
pouvez nous donner les grandes lignes un
budget toujours déficitaire cette année
absolument et on maintient le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2027 28 mai
cette eau routes pourraient s'accélérer
de toute évidence le gouvernement a des
marges de manoeuvre qui pourrait lui
permettre d'arriver au déficit zéro plus
rapidement qu'attendu mais pour 2022
23,6 milliards 500 millions de déficit
après un déficit de 7 milliards et demi
lors de l'exercice précédent et voyez
que l'an prochain on sera déjà un
déficit moindre de 3 milliards 900
millions le gouvernement met 2 milliards
400 millions encore pour soutenir les
gens dans le cadre de la coved 19 ayant
une provision très importante il ya la
guerre en ukraine en raison des risques
économiques qui y sont associés de 2
milliards 500 millions donc si vous en
veulent au levier ces deux sommes là on
serait pratiquement à l'équilibré
budgétaire à québec et ce qui va retenir
l'attention on en parle depuis plusieurs
jours c'est comment le quels moyens on a
choisi pour soulager les québécois face
à l'inflation et c'est une somme donc de
500 dollars pour aider les québécois qui
sera remise à toutes les personnes qui
déclarent pour 2021 un revenu de 100
mille dollars ou moins 100000 $ ou moins
toutes les tous les québécois c'est 6
millions 400 mille personnes au total
c'est une mesure que kiki vous sera
livre est offerte en quelque sorte dans
votre déclaration de revenus de 2021 et
si vous avez déjà fait votre déclaration
de revenus le gouvernement du québec va
communiquer avec vous le ministère des
finances va vous renvoyer un document
pour vous permettre de toucher la somme
de 500 $ le coût pour l'état 3 milliard
deux cents millions presque
essentiellement éponger dans l'exercice
financier d'avant cette somme la patrie
ce n'est même pas dans le budget
d'aujourd'hui c'est une somme qui est
con mais dans le budget 21-22 qui se
termine le 31 mars donc c'était vraiment
la mesure et je vous dirais que c'est la
principale mesure qui touche les
contribuables parce qu'ils paient pas de
taxes il n'y a pas de taxe à baisser la
tvq n'est pas abaisser par exemple sur
le prix de l'essence y a pas de gel de
tarif n'y a pas de baisses d'impôts la
somme principal pour les contribuables
c'est cette somme de 500 $ donc pour
aider les gens
à composer avec la hausse du coût dont
ce n'est pas un chèque envoyé aux gens
qui gagnent 100 mille dollars et moins
ceux qui ont déjà fait comme vous nous
le dites le rapport d'impôt pour 2021
doivent enfin rappelé refaire il y aura
des manières facile j'imagine ils ont
droit à 500 $ de plus ils n'ont rien à
faire le revenu québec va communiquer
avec va renvoyer un document mais la
majorité des gens n'ont pas encore fait
leur déclaration de revenus donc quand
vous allez faire votre déclaration de
revenus maintenant c'est la période des
impôts vous faites votre déclaration de
revenus pour 2021 vous aurez le 500 $
qui vous sera retourné donc par revenu
québec ce sera donc dans votre
déclaration de revenus c'est un montant
dont qui n'est pas imposable en quelque
sorte il fait partie de la déclaration
de revenus sous forme de crédits d'impôt
et c'est une somme qui est non
récurrentes donc ça ne reviendra pas les
prochaines années à moins que
l'inflation explose et que le
gouvernement prenne une autre décision à
ce moment là et vous nous dites qu'on
finance a dans le budget 21-22 exact
donc 3 milliards 200 millions dans
l'exercice 21-22 qui va se terminer le
31 mars donc ce n'est même pas dans le
budget dont on a pris connaissance
aujourd'hui 22 23 ce qu'il y a dans le
budget également aujourd'hui c'est de
l'argent en santé et en éducation
on investit 8 milliards 900 millions sur
cinq ans pour la refondation
ça commence là pour aider les
travailleurs l'accès aux données la
construction la rénovation des hôpitaux
les cliniques pour la corvée de l'ong
renforcer les soins à domicile et du
côté de l'éducation pour le tutorat
l'intégration des élèves issus de
l'immigration hausse de l'aide
financière aux étudiants aussi et
élimination des intérêts sur les prêts
étudiants on veut reconduire cette somme
et de l'argent pour la productivité ça
c'est pour aider les entreprises et plus
productive keanu plus de croissance au
québec 2 milliards 200 millions je
mentionne également qu'il ya de l'argent
pour les régions dans les secteur
bioalimentaire la forêt le tourisme le
transport aérien notamment le pq hui qu
on appelle le plan québécois des
infrastructures augmente de 7 milliards
500 millions 142 milliards 500 millions
sur 10 ans la mesure la plus importante
c'est la mise à l'étude du prolongement
de l'autoroute 20 jusqu'à rimouski de
gouvernement qui s'engage à étudier la
possibilité de prolonger l'autoroute 20
jusqu'à limoux ce qui est quand même un
enjeu très important pour les gens les
gens du bas saint laurent pas de
troisième lien ou de budget relié au
troisième mais non c'est à dire qu on
est toujours en planification sur le
troisième ligne et sur le tunnel entre
québec et lévis ça fait partie des
projets qui font partie du plan
québécois des infrastructures mais pas
de nouveau par rapport à cela vraiment
la mesure la plus nouvelle qui a
toujours de petites sommes qui sont pas
nécessairement des petites sommes et des
sommes qui sont liées aux transports
collectifs notamment mais la mesure la
plus importante aujourd'hui c'est cette
mise à l'étude du prolongement de tour
de vis très bien et l'inflation donc on
prévoit qu'on va qu'on va devoir vivre
avec exacte et le ministre relève quand
même de façon très importante la
prévision de l'inflation pour 2022 à 87%
savoir baisser quand même en 2023 pour
le pib la croissance économique de cette
année seulement 2% l'an prochain je vous
signale que c'est extrêmement faible
parce que le secteur privé prévoit plus
que ça donc non seulement le
gouvernement à des provisions sont liées
à l'inflation et à la guerre mais en
plus ils sous-estiment en quelque sorte
la croissance économique dont qui se
donne pas mal de marge de manoeuvre sur
l'environnement rouler vert est
reconduit un programme pour aider les
gens à acheter des véhicules électriques
à partir du 1er avril on abaisse les
rabais qui sont proposées aux québécois
de 8000 à 7000 $ pour l'achat d'un
véhicule entièrement électrique neuf de
huit mille à cinq mille dollars pour
véhicules hybrides rechargeables 9 et de
4000 à 3500 $ pour un véhicule
entièrement électrique d'occasions on
affirme que la demande est tellement
forte qu'on n'a pas besoin d'offrir des
rabais aussi important puis je termine
avec quelques mesures également qui ont
été annoncées patrice aujourd'hui 1000
nouveaux logements abordables qui
s'ajoutent aux 2200 déjà annoncé ça fait
partie d'une stratégie de plus de 600
millions pour le logement abordable
250 millions sur cinq ans pour la
relance touristique
255 millions pour le transport aérien
régional et seul le plein est attendue
depuis des mois mais on nous annonce que
ça s'en vient et la relance culturelle
258 millions et quand on regarde par
portefeuille la valeur du portefeuille
santé et services sociaux est rendu à 54
milliards de dollars
l'éducation à 19 milliards
l'enseignement supérieur à 10 milliards
en hausse de 13% ce qui est quand même
notable et les autres ministères à 44
milliards puis je vous donne un dernier
chiffre c'est la dette du québec qui est
à 199 milliards de dollars cela
représente presque 40% du produit
intérieur brut au jeu est ce qu'on peut
revenir à l'autre tableau sur la
croissance des dépenses en santé et
éducation
vous avez 10 6% gerald exact j'ai dit
6,3 pour cent pour santé et ça s'en
vient c'est revoir et éducation 5,4 pour
ça mais pour la santé et des services
sociaux c'est une croissance qui quand
même c'est ce que je suis ce qui m'a
frappé
le au delà de l'inflation on et ça c'est
le montant brut mais en tout cas le
tableau votre avant dernier on vole on
va le retrouver tout à l'heure dans les
analyses on va souligné ça donc en santé
la croissance continue à s'accélérer
voilà c'est existe trois donc oui ça
s'accélère et ça s'accélère
même si on est sorti ou pas mal sortis
ou en train de sortir de la pandémie
pourquoi parce que le ministre dubé à
parler de refondation du système de
santé donc faut investir dans les gens
dans les travailleurs faut investir
aussi dans les infrastructures il faut
investir beaucoup dans les soins à
domicile le soutien à domicile pour les
personnes aînées alors le gouvernement
donc maintient une accélération et je
vous signale qu'il répète sa demande au
gouvernement fédéral d'augmenter de
façon importante les transferts en santé
aux provinces la demande qui devient une
demande historique la des provinces et
réitérée dans ce budget mais n'empêche
pas quand même le gouvernement
d'accélérer d'augmenter quand même le
budget qui est prévu pour la santé et
des services sociaux c'est très clair
tous un gérald c'est très clair mais
ce qui nous frappe parce que je je je le
découvre comme les téléspectateurs en
même temps que les gens c'est qu'il n'ya
pas qu'en de yapo scapin foisonnement de
mesures qu'on aurait pu qualifier de pré
électorale exactement et donc
je ne souhaite pas qualifiés mois ci
c'est un budget électoraliste ou non
mais je peux vous dire que c'est un
budget qui préparent la campagne
électorale pour la raison simple que le
gouvernement avec une approche assez
prudente et conservatrice se donne de la
marge de manoeuvre 1 il ya une provision
de 2 milliards 500 millions il est
possible que ce ne soit pas nécessaire
d'utiliser la provision de 2 milliards
500 millions 2 les prévisions de
croissance économique sont très
conservatrices la part du ministère des
finances une vieille recette ça fait des
années qu'on fait ça mais cette année
c'est encore plus payant de le faire
donc peut-être quelques milliards qui
pourrait se dégager allez donc si la
situation en ukraine
dégénère au point de ralentir de façon
importante l'économie mondiale est de
créer un choc inflationniste ne veut
plus important le gouvernement a remis
de l'argent de côté mais si la situation
s'améliore le gouvernement aura des
marges de manoeuvre pour arriver en
campagne électorale et peut-être
promettre des baisses d'impôts très bien
gérald merci michel sébastien
je le disais on sait donc garder de
tomber là-dedans l'ex on ne voulait
surtout pas que demain toutes les
manchettes depuis ce soir aux
téléjournaux s'assoit budget électoral
est sûre on en met plein la vue beaucoup
de bonbons il ya le 500 $ qu'on veut que
les gens retiennent en fait oui puis le
500 $ le ministre des finances monsieur
virant le sort pas nécessairement de son
chapeau il ya un calcul d un
argumentaire derrière ce 500 $ parce que
ça avait créé des attentes dans l'idée
qu' on aurait un chèque avec le budget
qui s'en venait est ce que ce serait 500
600 700 us en dehors donc le
gouvernement le bas sur ce qu'on appelle
le panier de consommation donc le coût
de la vie essentiellement et faith et
fait quelques suivant la l'inflation
pour 2022 sera au tour de 4,7 pour cent
alors qu'on prévoyait autour de 2,6 on
compense la différence donc son
gouvernement avec ce chèque là par
rapport au panier de consommation c'est
quoi le panier de consommation
explications du ministre gyan on
compense pour le panier de consommation
de base c'est le logement l'alimentation
les vêtements le transport et est en ce
sens
tous les québécois sont touchés par la
hausse des valeurs et on a tiré une
ligne on a dit 6.4 millions de
contribuables sur un potentiel de six
points
c'est beaucoup de monde c'est 94% de la
population c'est pas le feu pour cent du
timide de côté c'est le 6 % de la
population qui a un nombre plus de cent
mille dollars qui mis de côté pour le
chèque de 500 $ mais c'est quand même
94% des adultes pour 94% de la
population mais 94% des adultes des gens
qui remplissent un rapport d'impôt une
déclaration de revenus qui vont avoir
droit
un montage jade entend de nos amis
économistes là dessus sur l'efficacité
ou pas mais en tout cas le minet se
défend d'avoir écrit un budget
électoraliste oui comme vous le disiez
c'est bien un budget électoraliste par
définition et au budget où il ya un feu
d'artifice ici est ce que c'est un feu
de bengale c'est des confettis il ya
quand même le chèque de 500 $ donc qui
peut être jugé électoraliste mais
l'argumentaire du gouvernement c'est
dire que élections au point élections
c'est à cause de l'inflation qu'on donne
ce chèque de 500 da mais ça se limite à
ça en termes de feu d'artifice y'a rien
d'autres mesures pour
pouvoir qualifier ce budget là d'
électoraliste en fait il est plus
prudent gérald le disait sur le taux de
croissance de l'économie notamment comme
si le gouvernement voulait peut-être se
dégager une marge de manoeuvre pour la
campagne et à faire des promesses
monsieur legault a déjà évoqué à voix
haute comme il le fait de temps en temps
dans sa plateforme électorale des
baisses d'impôts donc est ce qu'il y
aura des baisses d'impôts dans la
plateforme électorale peut-être mais
certainement il y en a pas dans ce
budget là est-ce que c'est électoraliste
voici la réponse du ministre gérant
il ya eu des budget électoraliste ou
québec et au fédéral et on pense que
c'est contreproductif les les pères de
taxes les citoyens voient ce qui se
passe savent que l'argent les 22
milliards de dépenses sur cinq ans que
ce électoralistes non je veux dire
pourquoi parce qu'on sort d'une pandémie
en fait il ya toujours une pandémie puis
on a de l'inflation
les partis d'opposition qu'est ce qu'ils
en disent il qualifie le budget d'
électoraliste en fait en mettant
l'accent sur le fait que le gouvernement
pourrait se dégager une marge de
manoeuvre avec une croissance économique
plus forte que ce qui prévaut dans le
budget avec cette provision aussi de
deux milliards et demi d'euros qui
pourrait permettre de financer des
promesses électorales donc les
oppositions sont pas du tout au diapason
avec le gouvernement c'est normal les
oppositions sont là pour s'opposer voici
un chapelet de réaction
sa priorité c'est pas le bien-être des
québécois mais bien de se faire réélire
monsieur le goût fait pleuvoir
des chèques dans le fond pour passer à
qu'elles sont trois tomes ça permet de
rejoindre 6,4 millions d'électeurs son
budget paternaliste où le gouvernement
continue d'augmenter ses revenus en
termes de taxes et d'impôts
très bien alors faisons un tour on à
l'économie selon muzi
présidente-directrice générale l'insu du
québec qui est avec nous michel suau j
vous êtes toujours là alors mis à
première réaction je vous emmènerai pas
sur le terrain politique mais vraiment
économique
le 500 dollars est ce que c'est une
mesure efficace
bon mais il ya plusieurs façons de les
regarder c'est sûr que d'un point de vue
purement économique
et on a toujours des réticences à se
dire est ce que c'est une bonne idée
d'ajouter autant d'argent dans
l'économie n'en font pour stimuler la
consommation aussi que ces trois points
2 milliards qui vont être dépensées je
sais pas sur une année ou deux par les
gens et donc c'est sûr que ça ajoute des
pressions inflationnistes
mais dans le contexte actuel quand même
beaucoup de pression aussi pour aider
les gens surtout ceux à plus faible
revenu à
compenser dans le fond d'une certaine
façon pour les packs de la hausse des
prix qu'on voit plus partout le
l'alimentation l'énergie etc et donc ça
se justifie surtout pour les plus
faibles revenus des questions un moindre
mal de compenser les revenus en italie
quand même un peu plus large peut-être
que on est très en journée on touche
quoi 90 % des adultes exactement moi je
pense que la mesure de l'automne dernier
je pense qu'elle était peut-être plus
adéquat parce qu'on visait vraiment les
gens qui bénéficient du crédit d'impôt
pour la solidarité dont 3.3 millions de
personnes quand même mais avec des
revenus plus faibles donc c'était plus
ciblées le bon c'est quand même
arbitraire le cir relativement
arbitraires les six ponts et 4 millions
de personnes puis le 5 cents de l'heure
mais au moins on n'y va pas du côté du
de geler les tarifs ce je trouve que
c'était encore plus dommageable parce
qu'après c'est difficile à défaire comme
décision au moins le sait une année mais
où il fait beaucoup d'argent ça va avoir
un impact probablement plus sur les
pressions inflationnistes et donc c'est
pas vraiment une solution et puis c'est
beaucoup d'argent pour une année où
est-ce qu'on a quand même un déficit de
7 points 5 milliards de dollars bon mais
parle aux gens de l' équilibre
budgétaire on vise toujours 27 28 pour
le retour à l'équilibré on met de
l'argent de côté pour la guerre pour la
pandémie encore dont on pourra ne pas ne
pas dépenser comment vous qualifier le
budget prudent audacieux mais c'est une
bonne question puis j'ai jonglé avec
sedan huis clos et puis ce que j'ai à
dire c'est que c'est un budget prudent
si tout va bien donc on voit pas les
équilibres budgétaires donc on reste
quand même avec 1 3 milliard environ de
mesures à identifier longtemps qu'on
parle de l'équilibré après les
versements au fonds des générations
avant ces versements là on atteint déjà
les équilibres dans quelques années leur
à court terme mais vu que la loi oblige
le gouvernement est à l'équilibré après
les versements on a quand même 1 3
milliard est identifié mais faut
relativiser parce que dans ce 3
milliards il ya quand même démarche de
prudence donc de 2.5 milliards l'an
prochain et ensuite 1.5 milliard pour
les années subséquentes
mais il ya aussi beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes l'on regarde les
prévisions économiques elles sont toutes
revues à la baisse le depuis quelques
jours et quelques semaines c'est sûr que
le budget il fallait qu'il soit imprimé
le cap port au début mars et donc ils
commencent à en tenir compte avec une
prévision relativement conservatrice la
2.5 pour cela il est en dessous de la
moyenne
secteur privé mais les dernières
prévisions du secteur privé sont à 2.7
2.6 et ça n'a fait que baisser
et donc il ya quand même des risques la
tuque une inflation est pas contrôler
tout le monde et espère qu'elles veulent
être et elles vont retourner dans la
fourchette de 1 à 3% d'ici un an mais
ses postures du tout je vais de gérald
et sébastien michel sauget à se joindre
à nous
la question c'est est ce que il a été
sébastien
quand même relativement prudents comme
dit mia si tout va bien en se gardant de
bonnes nouvelles dans six mois est ce
qu'il ya un peu ça ou pas il ya de ça et
il ya de ça traditionnellement dans les
budgets du gouvernement du québec c'est
comme si c'était un peu une culture
d'entreprise au ministère des finances
de promettre petit et de livrer plus
gros c'est à dire quand on voit de façon
très conservatrice la
l'augmentation du pib ou de la
production le leur et de la croissance
de l'économie et on arrive après sa 6
mois plus tard puis on se dit ah ça a
mieux été que ce qu'on avait prévu donc
on dégage des de l'argent donc on est
capable de réinvestir à tel ou tel
endroit donc oui c'est prudent
évidemment le feu d'artifice du 500
dollars c'est beaucoup d'argent plus de
3 milliards de dollars qui réinvestit
immédiatement mais c'est comme si
le gouvernement estime qu'on en avait
besoin pour combattre l'inflation
ralentirait les flèches mais de façon
générale il a été au delà de 500 $ il a
été plutôt prudent dans ses prévisions
économiques gerald vous êtes d'accord
donc un budget prudent on n'a pas voulu
trop en mettre oui exactement
prudent en
préparation de la campagne électorale
certainement mais prudent l'incertitude
est quand même grande je vous rappelle
que les risques sont importants avec le
l'inflation qui est galopante on n'a pas
encore vu le vrai chiffre de l'inflation
pour les prochains mois ça pourrait du 6
7 8 pour ça alors ça la guerre en
ukraine quel sera le véritable effet sur
l'économie mondiale ça pourrait nous
toucher je vous rappelle qu'on est
toujours en pandémie faut pas l'oublier
mais ça aussi peut arriver des avaries
sur la pandémie encore au cours des
prochains mois donc dans les
circonstances on joue de prudence mais
la stratégie elle est là entre la bonne
prudence si ça devait
dégénérer sur le plan économique on
pourra dire mais voilà on avait raison
de mettre de l'argent de côté mais si ça
vaut mieux que prévu finalement on aura
des sommes disponibles pour des mesures
fiscales en campagne électorale et pour
annoncer aussi l' équilibre budgétaire
beaucoup plus tôt qu'attendu mia sur le
rythme des dépenses de façon générale
santé éducation dans les missions
essentielles de l'état qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire mais honnêtement c'est énorme
je suis retourné hier fois dans les
budgets des années précédentes puis cetc
c'est le jour et la nuit le avant est
disons 2018 19 la croissance des
dépenses était beaucoup plus faible dans
les années post 2008 on avait des 2 3%
fallait justifier pourquoi on dépassait
de quelques dixièmes 2% qu'on est vrai
qu'on s'était engagé à faire reculer la
dynamique est complètement à l'opposé le
6,3 pour cent de dépenses annuelles
comme croissance de dépenses annuelles
moyennes en santé c'est énorme estime
que c'est après les dépenses de la
pandémie en plus le donc le ministère la
santé
énormément grossi tant en terme de
budget qu'en termes d'effectifs et puis
d'ailleurs on prive ou encore ajouter 10
mais l'effectif le à l'état et donc mais
premièrement faut se demander où est ce
qu'on va trouver ses effectifs là pour
livrer les services comment on va les
allées les attirer les garder et ensuite
ça va prendre la reddition de compte il
ya 2 9 milliards prestement aller en
santé au cours des cinq prochaines
années donc je pense que ce qu'il faut
retenir d'aujourd'hui c'est que eric
gérard dit à son collègue la santé je te
donne les moyens de ses ambitions pour
les réformes que tu veux entreprendre
mais là c'est qu'il va falloir voir
quelles sont ses cibles quels sont ses
objectifs comment il veut y arriver je
suis juste très important ce que veut
dire bien
là on ajoute 10 milliards les gens
s'attendent donc est ce que le système
fonctionne mieux oui c'est mais ça ça
sera jugée à terme ne sera pas jugée
dans
l'échéancier électoral
par contre moi je suis surpris de voir
été agréablement surpris de voir une
hausse des dépenses de 5 4% pour les
prochaines années en éducation on aurait
pu penser qu étant donné l'argent qu'on
allait donner à la santé il resterait
pas pas beaucoup pour l'éducation c'est
souvent ce qui est arrivé dans les
dernières années l'éducation tel parent
pauvre on essaie de corriger ça mais il
ya des chiffres qui me surprennent une
inflation prévue en 2022 de 4 7% on sait
déjà qu'on est bien au delà de ça je pas
sûr qu'à la fin le cssc bon de 500 $
mais à la fin c'est moins de 10 $ par
semaine pour les gens qui vont le
recevoir c'est pas une compensation si
grande que ça surtout si comme gérald
vient de dire dans ce que l'inflation se
retrouve à 7 8% à la fin de l'année la d
quand même je sais jouer wazi gestation
qu'on s'attend quand même je vous ai je
veux pas faire peur à personne j'ai 17
8% l'homme et on s'attend quand même
dans la deuxième moitié de 2022 on
essaie que l'inflation baisse alors
ralentissent en quelque sorte de là
probablement le calcul de dire la
moyenne de l'année 4,7 mais ça pourrait
être plus effectivement ça pourrait
aussi tourné autour des 5%
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre jal vous en
parler à tous les soirs où près les gens
nous en parlent des consorts qu'on a un
échange économique avec un commerçants
restaurateurs une zone industrielle
ça revient est ce que quelque chose dans
le budget pour faire face à ça ou pas 9
moi ce que je vois c'est encore en fait
je pense le groupe de travail le message
c'est que le groupe travaille pour le
gouvernement c'était le plan de
l'automne le 3.9 milliards d'opérations
main d'oeuvre c'était seul ici vraiment
ce que dans le budget c'est à peine si
c'est beaucoup centré sur les secteurs
publics donc la santé l'éducation dans
les taux de dépenses de croissance de
dépenses dans ton dont on ne parlait il
ya des mesures prévues pour attirer
retenir des enseignants du personnel de
la santé donc se sait bien qu'ils ont
pas de réorganisation la du de tout ce
qui est gestion de la main d'oeuvre so
sexy fondamentale mais il ya vraiment il
ya vraiment pas grand chose le pour le
secteur privé c'est des grenades oui le
gouvernement compte sur la productivité
sur l'automatisation les technologies
donc monsieur girard le divin % de ma
croissance économique vient de l'offre
de travailleurs supplémentaires et 80%
vient de la productivité donc de
l'investissement aujourd'hui de 2
milliards 200 millions pour tenter
d'aider les entreprises à améliorer leur
productivité
mais la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre demeure
entière là ça va prendre une éternité
avant de régler cet enjeu là compte tenu
du désavantage numérique du québec c'est
à dire que nous allons vivre un
vieillissement de la population nous le
vivons déjà qui est important et qui va
faire énormément de pression sur la
population active et sur les finances
publiques également dans les prochaines
années j'ai quand même noter aussi pour
l'enseignement supérieur le budget de
l'enseignement supérieur augmente de 13%
donc un investissement important dans le
budget de l'enseignement supérieur pour
former du monde pour aller sur le marché
du travail en espérant probablement que
les gens vont aller au cégep et à
l'université vont être mieux formés pour
le marché or donc éducation santé on
donne un quand même un gros coup
d'accélérateur
si je peux compléter pour l'enseignement
supérieur justement c'est fini pour en
lien avec votre question oui un gros
coup mais là dedans il ya vraiment une
grosse partie de la croissance cris
réservé aux bourses qui ont été
annoncées à l'automne donc et vu qu'on
finance une partie est des frais de
scolarité pour les parcours le qui ont
été identifiés c'est sûr que ça fait
exploser le budget puis ensuite le aussi
où est ce qu'on prend c'est un peu
surprenant sur la main d'or c'est qu'on
aurait pu penser qu'il y aurait des
mesures pour les travailleurs de 60 ans
et plus parce qu'on sait que le québec
un record assez important qu'on se
compare à lons à l'ontario sur le taux
d'emploi de cette tranche le lit travers
de 60 à 69 ans qui dans discours du
ministre boulet ben il ya beaucoup
souvent il revient sur l'élément qu'on
peut en faire plus mais y avait rien
dans le budget là dessus
sébastien est donc le ministre et on va
dans quelques minutes à refaire les
faits saillants mesdames et messieurs
mes questions plus politiques donc le
ministre a livré ce budget-là à son
gouvernement est il bien équipé pour la
campagne qui dans une certaine mesure et
déjà commencé on le voi il est il est
équipé parce que il met de l'argent de
côté il a des prévisions de croissance
économique sont inférieures à celles du
secteur privé donc ils c'est comme s'il
se dégage une marge de manoeuvre pour la
campagne électorale pour pour les
promesses électorales donc il fait son
écureuil un peu m côté de l'argent il
est prudent il fait pas de folles
dépenses il n'augmente pas les budgets
apparent santé pour la refondation du
réseau de la santé dans l'expression du
gouvernement à part ça il fait pas de
grosses dépenses ou d'augmentation des
budgets des ministères donc il est
prudent mais pour voir au delà de
l'arbre il ya la forêt derrière l'arbre
et cette foire est là c'est la campagne
électorale qu'il prépare quand même avec
ce budget très bien pour les gens qui se
sont joints à nous il ya quelques
minutes gerald refaisons si vous le
voulez bien les faits saillants de ce
budget du monsieur gérard alors budget
déficitaire
bien que le déficit s'amoindrit
tranquillement 6 milliards 500 millions
pour l'exercice 2010 22 23 déficit de 6
milliards 500 millions qui comprend je
vous dis une provision de 2 milliards
500 millions en raison des risques
économiques notamment liées à la guerre
en ukraine qui comprend également deux
milliards et demi pour la coved 19 et le
fonds des générations trois milliards et
demi donc si j'ai face à tout cela je
serai à l'équilibré budgétaire déjà
cette année alors avec 2 milliards 400
millions et 2 milliards 500 millions la
nouvelle où le chiffre qu'on va retenir
donc ses 500 $ 500 $ pour les personnes
gagnant 100 mille dollars ou moins pour
compenser le coût de la vie le coût de
la vie qui augmente
l'inflation qui est qui est au rendez
vous de façon importante et donc c'est
dans votre déclaration de revenus 2021
vous pouvez toucher ce 500 $ dès
maintenant en faisant votre déclaration
de revenus et si vous avez déjà fait
votre déclaration de revenus le
gouvernement
revenu québec va vous envoyer un nouveau
document pour être capable de retraiter
votre déclaration de revenus et toucher
les 500 dollars le coût est de 3
milliards 200 millions et ses six
millions 400 mille personnes qui vont
pouvoir en bénéficier
les infrastructures 142 milliards 500
millions sur 10 ans c'est une
augmentation de 7 milliards 500 millions
dans le budget des infrastructures sur
sur dix ans donc toujours des projets
routiers
majoritairement des projets routiers et
ensuite du transport collectif mais là
je vous dirais que deux tiers du budget
est vraiment pour des travaux routiers
élargissement construction construction
de tours 19 notamment
élargissement de l'autoroute 30 si je me
rappelle bien et on met à l'étude
également le prolongement de l'autoroute
20 jusqu'à rimouski l'inflation à 4 7%
2022 et je vous le signale je vous le
rappelle en fait pas de baisses d'impôts
pas de baisses de taxes pas de gel de
tarif le gouvernement donc qui concentre
son intervention pour l'instant avec
cette somme exceptionnelle en temps
exceptionnel pour aider les gens à faire
face au coût de la vie et on l'a dit un
gérald en santé en éducation
on remet de l'argent pas mal pour les
prochaines années santé une croissance
de plus de 6 pour ça éducation
supérieure on le dit là c'est une
dizaine de pourcentage
éducation générale ces 5,2 je crois donc
on remet de l'argent dans l'émission
important importante de l'état
exactement on mise beaucoup sur ce
travail qui a à faire pour solidifier
système de santé après les deux années
très difficiles qu'on a connu avec la
pandémie pour investir davantage dans le
soutien à domicile pour les personnes
aînées pour construire et rénover les
hôpitaux également et d'un secteur de
l'éducation pour également rénové mais
soutenir favoriser la réussite scolaire
la pandémie n'a pas été facile non plus
pour la diplomation c'était difficile
d'étudier pendant la pandémie alors il
ya de l'argent là dessus je vous
mentionne par ailleurs parce qu'on parle
de santé d'éducation il ya beaucoup
d'argent segment supérieur mais les
autres ministères ses 44 milliards et la
hausse n'est d'à peine qu'un pour cent
des 1 % presse les autres on compresse
les autres la croissance des dépenses
est très très faible pour les autres
ministères on concentre sur les grandes
missions de l'état bon mais justement sa
relance au tour de table
l'environnement général vous avez dit
tout à l'heure pour les voitures
électriques
on est en retard sur l'objectif du du
québec et là on va baisser si j'ai bien
compris les subventions pour ceux qui
achètent des voitures électriques
pourquoi exactement donc la baisse se
fait par ce que nous dit on au ministère
des finances le coût de production des
véhicules automobiles électriques baisse
et la demande et même le prix des
véhicules électriques baisse parce que
de plus en plus d'offres sur papier
parce que les véhicules électriques ne
sont pas disponibles ça prend six à
douze mois quand vous commandez
véhicules électriques et la demande est
au rendez vous donc on se dit on ne peut
pas besoin d'appuyer autant qu'on
devrait parce que de toute façon les
gens veulent des véhicules électriques
alors on se dit qu'on peut abaisser de
8000 à 7000 la subvention pour les
véhicules entièrement
électriques neufs de vie mais là 5000
pour les véhicules hybrides
rechargeables 9 et de quatre mille à
trois mille cinq cent sont des véhicules
entièrement électriques d'occasions je
veux entendre mais mes amis là dessus
parce que sébastien ça peut paraître je
comprends qu économiquement s'il est le
prix baissent mais on veut encourager au
maximum les gens non à rouler vert oui
puis on avait un incitatif en fait on a
des objectifs d'éliminer les véhicules
électriques au cours des prochaines
années des véhicules essence sur les
routes du québec au cours des prochaines
années on se fixe donc un objectif
ambitieux et en même temps on réduit les
rabais pour l'achat de véhicules
électriques à première vue le mot que
vous avez pas dit c'est ça paraît
contradictoire et moi j'ai l'impression
que les gens qui veulent acheter des
véhicules électriques compte sur ces
rabais ils ont comme planifié leur
commande de véhicules électriques même
si de la livraison et dans six à douze
mois en pensant qu'ils auraient une
grosse subvention du gouvernement elle
reste quand même relativement gros ça on
passe de 8000 à 7000 comme subvention
mais un mille dollars c'est quand même
un mille dollars donc qu'on pourrait
réaliser dans d'autres choses donc ça
paraît à première vue contradictoires
selon les objectifs que le gouvernement
s'est lui même fixé on espère que le
prix des véhicules sera moins élevée on
a comme un doute aussi en même temps et
on comptait peut-être sur ce rabais du
gouvernent oui michel qu'en pensez vous
je pense que le gouvernement fait aussi
le pari que
les gens qui achètent des véhicules
électriques actuellement sont déjà plus
fortunés et que peut-être le mille
dollars oui c'est 1000 $ mais c'est pas
si important que ça dans leur décision à
court terme je pense que c'est
probablement le pari qu'ils font je veux
voir lancer une autre baisse si vous me
permettez on a parlé logement tout à
l'heure et logement à ça des effets sur
toutes sortes de choses y compris
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre région et
cetera pour accroître l'offre de
logements sociaux et de logements
abordables 416 millions c'est vraiment
peu quand on sait les besoins de ce côté
là et qu'on va les écrans c'est aussi
comme ça peut améliorer la qualité de
vie des gens
s'il ya des marges de manoeuvre pour la
campagne électorale peut être qu'ils
devraient les noms mais si vous faites
du coup sur les logements il n'y a pas
des non plus pour l'accès à la propriété
vous savez que les maisons l'achat d'une
résidence ça monte en flèche c'est
devenu extrêmement coûteux il ya une
surenchère même des gens font des offres
un jour puis dans l'après-midi le matin
puis l'après midi il ya une surenchère
sur l'offre qu'ils ont fait donc c'est
très difficile pour les jeunes d'accéder
à la propriété il n'y a rien dans le
budget en que j'ai rien vu pour aider à
l'accès à la propriété donc quand on
parle de mesures pour combattre
l'inflation on se limite vraiment au
chèque de 500 da et de mémoire me hamdi
les québécois sont propriétaires à la
hauteur de
61% et la moyenne canadienne et 68% donc
est en retard à rattraper pour l'accès à
la propriété
aux nouveaux brand ou et tout à l'heure
on disait il ya des aides quand même
importante qui ont été annoncés
aujourd'hui dans le budget pour réduire
les taxes foncières et c'est ce qui
aurait pas eu là un champ d'action
important c'est sûr que c'est un
problème là on le vit de plus en plus
peas i've vraiment avec la pandémie puis
les mesures de soutien aux revenus le
fait qu'à consommation pouvait pas être
dirigés vers les services ça amplifie sa
empirer le problème est donc c'est bien
réel au début on voyait que c'était
beaucoup plus présents et en colombie
britannique en ontario à toronto tout
seul et on était encore un peu moins un
peu épargné et au québec et à montréal
mais là était entraîneur à trappes et
puis c'est un enjeu c'est vrai que rien
dans le budget mais c'est extrêmement
complexe aussi parce que quand on essaye
d'aider des jeunes familles mais on
vient des fois aussi amplifier le
mouvement quand on donne plus de
liquidités mais ça ça accroît sa rend
l'accès encore plus difficile parce a
fait monter les prix et donc une des
vraies solutions dont on parle pas
beaucoup mais ça va être aussi un peu la
hausse des taux d'intérêt tu vas venir
probablement calmé un peu de marche et
c'est accroître l'offre de logement
c'est légiférer sur la spéculation
puis surtout les acheteurs étrangers qui
viennent donc ce sont les leviers qu'on
voit le plus souvent qui sont utilisés
on en a eu un peu dans le dernier budget
la mise à jour économique mais yo rien
cette fois ci dans le budget ouais
gérald eux s'étaient pas au menu non le
ministre girard a dit aujourd'hui qu'il
ne croit pas qu'il ya une crise de
l'accès à la propriété au québec et il
compare beaucoup nos prix avec ceux de
toronto et de vancouver
qui sont le dos blanc de montréal par
exemple si le triple des grands centres
du québec donc pour lui il n'ya pas un
enjeu absolument
profonds et importants bien qu'il y a
quand même un enjeu pour les jeunes
ménages qui sont obligés de s'éloigner
très souvent des grands centres pour
être capable d'avoir accès à la
propriété qu'il recherche puis un enjeu
en région là dessus il ya plus de
logements disponibles dans beaucoup de
villes de grandeur moyenne au québec
allait faire un tour du moose qui grande
bd des villes comme ça y'a plus le jus
indisponible alors comment une compagnie
peut faire de prendre de l'expansion et
agit du nouveau monde s'il ya pas de
logement la région et ça c'est un
problème est et le secteur privé et pas
très intéressé actuellement à qui a créé
de bâtir de ces logements là donc il
faut de l'intervention gouvernementale
et je prends que vous allez entendre
plusieurs maires de région au cours des
prochains jours dit elle ça c'est un
problème chez majeur chez nous et il
faudrait que ken une offre du
gouvernement là dessus on va entendre le
président lui-même qu d'ailleurs dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord notre
collègue colin côté paul est à québec
qu'on a pu avoir des premières réactions
j'imagine que le 500 dollars c'est ce
qui fait réagir
ça fait beaucoup réagir patrice des
réactions mitigées je voudrais d'emblée
parce qu'il ya des gens qui nous disent
wow quel cadeau de fin d'année bas de
début d'année par dont le maître fin
d'année fiscale ça nous impressionnent
on est content il ya d'autres gens qui
nous disent 500 dollars ok mais qu'est
ce que ça change dans mon année il ya
même une dame qui m'a dit j'ai
l'impression de me faire acheter donc
des réactions partagées mais on voit que
ça fait beaucoup jaser on l'apprend gens
puis souvent si on écoute un peu nos
émissions c'est la première chose dont
une part dans la rue où elle 500 $
qu'est-ce que si tout ça donc beaucoup
de réaction là dessus tout de suite on
va aller voir un extrait de ce box par
des gens qui j'ai parlé ont vécu leur
réponse un beau 500 $ effectivement
qu'on refuse de poisson avec l'inflation
plus le coût de la vie donc j'avoue que
soudainement je suis très content très
peu imposante tant mieux c'était
boukadous sinon ben tant pis on va payer
pour réussir d'union de la moitié passe
tout près simonian de la chercheure
n'est pour 2023 ben j'ai l'impression
d'en faire acheter
carrément parce que je dise 500 pièces
et quads aujourd'hui c'est tout les
rangers l'épicerie de ces foulées
l'électricité des logements tout monde
c'est comme ça me donne un petit cadeau
que je me la fermer
bon le minet cyr entendent ça doit être
découragée merci beaucoup je vais
attendre midi là dessus
alors je vous repose la question
mia est ce qu'il y aurait eu un autre
levier un autre outil est ce que 500 on
est allé vous avez du talent on est allé
peut-être un peu le large où vous en
êtes là sur la note de ge à dire sur
cette mesure du 500 dollars
mais c'est un moindre mal d'agir sur les
revenues donc je pense que l'idée de
compenser par un chai coin un crédit
d'impôt remboursable je pense que
c'était la bonne décision qui n'est pas
d'aller sur une baisse d'impôts par
exemple ou sur des demandes pressantes
le de geler des tarifs ou d'abolir des
taxes sur l'essence s'arrêter pire mais
c'est sûr que c'est très controversé
parce que pour certaines personnes c'est
pas assez ceux qui la ressentent
beaucoup plus loin parce que l'inflation
passe qui prennent beaucoup leur
véhicule ou parce qu'ils ont défait le
revenu et je pense que la mesure aurait
eu un plus grand effet si on avait pris
ce 3.2 milliards puis on l'avait
vraiment répartis sur les 3 points et 3
millions de personnes qui en ont
vraiment besoin qui bénéficie déjà d'un
coup de pouce avec le crédit solidarité
le sari eu un impact chez les personnes
qui en ont vraiment besoin oui aurait
vainement que qui en aurait bénéficié
mais il faut se rappeler quand même
quelque chose on oublie plus on est très
concentrés sur l'inflation mais si on
retourne dix ans en arrière les salaires
le salaire moyen au québec a augmenté
plus rapidement que l'inflation donc les
salaires réels ont été en croissance
plus que dans un autre lieu plus qu'au
canada donc le marché du travail ça
juste aussi aux yeux des mécanismes qui
font en sorte qu'il ya d'autres
compensations qu'il ya des gens qui ont
les moyens il ya des gens qui ont eu
avec qui on peut sentir les impacts au
niveau de leurs revenus la pandémie qui
peuvent tolérer cette augmentation le
temporaire du coût de la vie donc on a
embrassé trolard jusqu'au bout dit oui
dans la méthode était la bonne mais on a
embrassé trop large on aurait pu en
donner plus à moins de monde mais c'est
ça on a dilué les faits qu'on aurait pu
avoir sur les personnes très touché on a
essayé de couvrir plus large mais c'est
que pour certaines personnes c'est pas
un essai c'est marginal puis c'était pas
nécessaire éviter le côté électoraliste
du budget il elop a passé sa roue dieu 2
au lieu de cibler ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin de 10,6 millions point cap
déjà vous recevoir un chèque et ça c'est
bon je pense que meilleure raison ce
sera été beaucoup plus efficace de le
cibler encore une fois aux gens qui
reçoivent les crédits des possibilités
là donc c'est déjà le cours a été moins
large la noce - l'âge mais peut-être
plus efficace pour ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin la personne qui coûte
qu'igor une cent mille dollars par année
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire avec son 500
$ est ce qu'elle va s'acheter un ipad ou
un téléviseur peut-être que ça va lui
donner le goût d'acheter quelque chose
qu autrement elle ne se serait pas
acheté par contre les personnes qui
gagnent 50 mille dollars le 500 dollars
va venir l'aider à payer l'augmentation
de son logement l'augmentation de
l'épicerie donc si on voit les choses de
cette façon là c'est beaucoup plus
ciblées beaucoup plus efficace pour
quelqu'un qui gagne moins d'argent ça
sera une des questions qu'on va poser au
ministre girard qui sera avec nous au
téléjournal à 18h30 sera t'il pu être
plus limité mais les faire et témoins
alors voici l'édition voilà voici où
l'élection entre en jeu sébastien on les
a écoutés tout à l'heure on va les
écouter réaction de l'opposition
tout le monde doit acheter ses produits
essentiels à la pharmacie que ce soit
des médicaments sans ordonnance à ce
soit de savons que ce soit des
shampoings peu importe qu'on enlève la
tvq sur ces produits là ça c'est
structurant que nos concitoyens puissent
respirer un peu notamment
considérant la crise du coût de la vie
une modulation de cette allocation la
fonction des revenus donc les gens qui
gagnent moins d'argent lors plus dans
leurs poches et ceux et celles qui ont
l'opportunité de contribuer mais
effectivement il sera hôte aussi reconnu
avec notre allocation sur le pouvoir
d'achat le problème avec un chèque c'est
que c'est très payant politiquement
d'envoyer un chèque avec des élections
pour acheter des votes mais
malheureusement économiquement ça n'a
pas de sens
bon alors mis à vous dit sans arrêt oui
ça peut avoir un sens mais si on avait
été plus ciblée ça aurait été mieux mais
surtout si on avait pris ce même montant
l'appui qu'on la verrait parti pour sur
la moitié de moins de personnes donc le
3.3 millions de personnes à plus faible
revenu au lieu de 6 points 4 c'est sûr
que pour ces personnes là ça aurait eu
un effet est l'écrin compte tenu du fait
qu'on invite quand même beaucoup
d'argent et dans l'économie ça va
stimuler la consommation puis ça va
avoir un impact le ca va accroître les
pressions inflationnistes
ben ça c'est sûr que c'est pas
souhaitable en ce moment parce que l'on
compte tout le monde compte sur la
banque du canada pour gérer l'inflation
en relevant les taux et mais on vient
pas aidé avec 6,6 si tous les
gouvernements commencent à faire cela de
façon répétée et on va perpétuer notre
problème d'inflation va fort concède
aussi un moment donné si on veut en
sortir très bien petit mot avant de
conclure cette portion des missions la
santé oms mais quand même
de l'argent passablement c'est
l'augmentation est assez importante le
6,1 santé s'cusez 3par dont 6,3 6,3 en
santé c'est beaucoup d'argent à
sébastien et là il faut que monsieur
dubé partent avec ça puis qu'il commença
refondation pour que les gens y voit une
différence cette augmentation de budget
vous donne une pas mal belle fondation
du nouveau système de santé que veut se
donner le gouvernement mais maintenant
c'est sa place à bord aussi on voit que
le gouvernement va vouloir investir
beaucoup d'argent dans le système de
santé va falloir que les résultats
soient là sauf que les résultats ils
seront pas les à court terme ils vont
être là un moyen et à long termes
monsieur devait a dit que ça lui
prendrait cinq ans mais la table est
mise si on veut il ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que christian dubé va
voir l'argent qu'il veut avoir pour
faire sa réforme du réseau de la santé
comment il va faire cette réforme c'est
être déterminée mais disons qu'on peut
s'attendre à ce que il est le chèque et
l'effort nécessaire pour le faire très
bien merci beaucoup avocat gerald un
petit mot à quelques secondes donc être
vous d'accalmie hawzi prudent si tout va
bien quoi oui prudent si tout va bien
mais heureusement prudent compte tenu de
toutes les incertitudes dans lesquelles
nous sommes
l'inflation la guerre en ukraine la
pandémie il est normal d'être prudent et
si par exemple la prudence se
transformer en croissance économique un
peu plus forte ça donnerait donc une
belle marge de manoeuvre pour le
gouvernement merci beaucoup à vous
quatre on se retrouve ou 17h merci
mesdames et messieurs de votre attention
on va donc décortiqué aussi ce budget et
d'autres nouvelles importantes de la
journée dans quelques minutes merci de
votre attention
[Musique]